my talk is called from rest to graph QL
so my goal here is not to say like Oh
rest is not good use graph cool it's
going to be more of like an exploration
of how we currently fetch data for apps
right now and how graph QL can help and
what it does differently so a bit about
me I'm a wizard working at it was the
word software wizard or something I
don't remember but I'm that at Shopify
we as my friend Simon said yesterday he
was also from a shallow fire we
basically make commerce easier for our
merchants and help them sell things
micro services unrelated slide I just
wanted to have that word there
so I want to start with a simple UI
component and we'll walk through like
how could we get data to populate that
component so let's take for example this
is a shopping cart and a github shop so
it's pretty simple but we still need a
lot of data right to render all this so
what kind of data exactly do we need so
we have a cart probably cart resource
with probably a total and it has
products we have the products themselves
which probably have a title description
price a bunch of other things and maybe
also product image that's gonna contain
do URL of the image any metadata we need
so using like reusable endpoints or
something like rest we like the concept
of rest right we have like resources and
if you're truly rest you'll have like
Kipling's hyperlinks to other resources
and yeah basically you have state and
you can move to other states through
links right so how it ends up happening
often is we're gonna get the cart the
cart resource is gonna return us a bunch
of H rafts or IDs but mostly like H
rafts towards the products we're gonna
fetch those and the products resources
might have links towards your product
images and we're going to fetch those
too so I mean that works we have the
data we need but a lot of like users
today are on mobile phones on 3G
networks even worse sometimes and that's
seven round trips of course I'm sure no
one here actually does that right in the
front end nobody does like seven round
trips so that's way too many round trips
right we need something to reduce that
amount especially on mobile and like
slow Network
so maybe from their gonna get oh I can
use a query param on my cart and I can
expand my association so like please
include products in my first request so
that works but at the same time you risk
you still risk over fetching because
maybe you only needed the price or name
of the product but now you're stuck with
a whole resource so maybe you'll do
something even more clever like a fields
query param where you say exactly what
you need but that's still that's like
only one level deep right if you have
nested associations it gets like even
like you kind of have to reinvent the
wheel every time I've seen like XPath
being used it's just a little annoying
and there's no convention right yeah
everybody tries to do their their own
thing so that's one thing
another solution you might be tempted to
use is custom end points so I want data
for my cart but I only one round trip
and I I want exactly what I want nothing
more nothing less
so it's pretty easy right I have an end
point card with all the stuff I need
we're done it's perfect but that might
start with this but then maybe you're
gonna have another page in your app
which also a cart but has slightly
different needs maybe more products
maybe less products maybe different
images so maybe you'll have a card
version too with all the things perfect
maybe you'll have cart with products and
images and maybe you'll have a query
parameter say how many images you want
maybe you'll have card with products and
images with price and taxes if you'll
have card with product dimensions with
prices and taxes but no description and
that gets like pretty ugly red of course
we don't go that far but you get the
point
so it's kind of annoying but what can we
do like to have exactly what we want but
still have a solution that's chaos well
and it is not two coupled doesn't make
the client two coupled with our the
server endpoints right so like
when a client updates a view creates a
new view or maybe we have a new product
view for like another product or the
model of the product changes every time
we go to update our endpoints in that
case or create new endpoints and that's
kind of annoying so graph QL is here to
help us
what is graph QL actually let's start
with what a graph girl is not graph girl
is not a database it's not some special
kind of graph database it's not a
library
you can't just install graph QL with
instant results it's not language
specific right it's not a ruby thing
it's not a JavaScript thing what it is
is a query language that allows you to
fetch like deeply nested associations
and select exactly what you want plus
aspect for servers to execute these
queries so it's just aspect right so
you'll see implementations of in Ruby
you'll simply made it you know
JavaScript server really any language so
this is a really simple graph fueled
query it's kind of like the hello world
graph QL so what I have here are
brackets selection set basically
telegraphed well what I want to select
on that object and I have fields inside
these brackets inside these selection
sets so when I send that courage our
graphic real server what happens well
it's like any other language it's Lex
it's parsed it's validated it's executed
and we get a nice response and the
response format is pretty interesting
because it follows the exact pattern
then you request right it's just jason
with the same shape as you request
that's pretty cool so name was obviously
a field on my shop but what the hell is
my shop right where does it come from is
it like some grass troll magic I don't
know
so it turns out so graphical models your
data as a graph right but it still needs
entry points to that graph right you
can't just enter from anywhere in your
data so graph girl has this concept of
query route where you define entry
points where can I start my query from
so we had my shop before but I might do
another entry point which shop that
takes an ID it might return the same
result but there are different entry
points this one is like more
programmatic way of doing it my shop
maybe just returned the shop you're
logged in or something so let's take a
more complex example this time so we
have new things right here we don't only
fetch the name of the shop we can fetch
complex subjects associations on that
shop so I have the location which I only
want to see the address and a list of
products and I want the name and price
of each of those and it's ordered by
argument which is an enum so as you
could have guessed it's just the
response is the query with values so all
that's possible because at the core of
graph QL is a really powerful type
system at every level of a graphical
query there's a type attached to it and
that type exposes all that objects
fields basically it exposes all the
possibilities so for example let's take
the same query my shop here as we talked
about earlier is on a query route right
so we have a type query route and it
tells me oh I can query my shop or a
Chaba ID and both of those return a shop
type so on the shop type recurring name
location in products am I allowed to do
that you can look at a type of shop and
see that it exposes the name location in
products name is a simple what we'll
call a scalar type so it just returns a
string while location and products are
more complex type object types if we
continue here
we City and address are selected from
location from an address and it exposes
those fields same with products we have
types are everything right so that's
really cool it actually shows you like
you can't query so it's not a one-to-one
mapping with your database graph feel
right it's just like a layer and you
expose only the fields you want to
expose and with the type system it
doesn't let you do otherwise and you
know which types you're expecting
so fragments sometimes we want to
decompose things so right now we only
have it like one big query and you can
imagine for more complex you is it gets
even bigger sometimes it makes a little
more sense to like decompose those into
smaller queries and graph girl makes
that possible
so let's take a look at the same query
again
in like we talked a lot about react this
years just anything like confident
component based you eyes so if we take a
look at let's say this was my product
component in red it basically only needs
what products have red an ID a name in a
price so what we can do is extract this
from the original query and create a new
fragment with it so all we need is name
it so I'm naming my fragment product
fields and say on which type this
fragment applies that lets the that's
lets us do something really interesting
by using fragments inside your like main
query and that's really cool because if
you have like let's say a main root
component and like children you can
decompose that query into each of the
children and at runtime when you
actually need the data every children
passes its fragment to the parent query
we can send that like in one query when
we get it back we can give it back to
children so this is my favorite part of
all graph QL its ability to introspect
itself and what I mean by that is that
every graph QL server
as a special schema field at the query
route and using that you can actually
expose all of objects in fields in a
graphical server and this allows us to
create really nice tools for example
Auto documentation right we can ask for
a server
what are your fields and objects and
these fields and objects usually have
names and descriptions plus every field
they are they can let you use so you
have free documentation code generation
you can imagine if you have some
front-end code you might even be able to
guess what query do you need and
generate it because you know what's
possible and not static validation you
don't even need to let a query go to the
server and then get rejected because you
know beforehand if that query is valid
or not
so I des can validate your your queries
and they can autocomplete your queries
because they know everything about the
schema so this with this we can build
awesome tomb-like tools like graphical
graphical is kind of a schema Explorer
for a graph QL so you can try like
anything you want really quickly on a
server and on the right you see there's
like documentation you can explore every
type and try really any queries and when
I saw that for the first time it's
really when like I realized like this is
really cool
so resolving fields so far we've talked
about fields object types but we have
actually no idea like what happens on
the server is you don't just like pass
in a schema and a query and you get
magic data right so if we take for
example the product type this is an
example of how you define it in Ruby so
it's an object type we give it a name in
a description and we can define fields
on it so fields are really just simple
function is in the end they expose
something called resolve and in resolve
you do whatever whatever you want so in
this case for name
the result function takes three
arguments the first argument object is
the parent object in this case it'd be
like a product object object arguments
and a query context that's like global
to the query so here to get the name of
a product it's simply like object up
name right because it's a product but
like I said it's not a one-to-one
mapping to the database right we can do
anything we want for price we might add
a bunch of stuff and return it so and
with all this all your fields have the
resolved function so when you have a
query the server is going to turn it
into an AST walk that AST and call the
result functions and build build a
response and queries can be pretty large
right so we have to post and we'll see
how it can be a little annoying later
we've only seen read-only but we can
write to in graphical they're called
mutations and they look pretty much
exactly like a normal field the only
difference is that they're only on the
root we have a query route in a mutation
route so they're not nested they're
top-level actions and they have
side-effects but you can still select
the returner type and you can still
select what we want from the response so
draw box because it's not like a Silver
Bullet right it has to have like some
disadvantages so if you implement the
graphical server naively you're gonna
run into a lot of n plus 1 queries and
what I mean by that I'll show you in
this example so we have a field product
and that's on a shop type and it returns
all the products in a shop we also have
a field image that one imagine it's on
the product type and it's simply product
that image so if you run a query that
ask for products and their images nested
you might get something like this in
your logs right so I selected all
products and all of sudden images are
all loaded individually and normally
you'll be like oh that's
easy just like preload them or like make
sure you do like we're in these IDs so
in graphical it's a bit hard right
because resolve functions are all ran in
different contexts and it can even be
random concurrently so how can you do
like get all images at one time and for
that solution is a lot of batching and a
lot of caching and I'm just going to
talk about how we do batching and how
actually most people using graphical do
bashing is by using something like
loaders and loaders what we do basically
is instead of immediately returning the
product image for example we're gonna
say loader
I want that image but don't fetch it
just yet I'm just gonna give you the ID
when all the other products in the array
have given you your IDs
fetch all of them and return the one I
want so we're batching all these IDs and
saying to order I only want that one but
I fetch all of them at the same time so
that solves it pretty well another issue
we run into is HTTP caching because we
post and because our queries are not yet
impotant anymore we can't really use
that right we have to find another way
and that solution often is a client-side
cache and this is the part that takes
the more the most time and it's the most
difficult part to get we graph cool but
it turns out it works really well and it
allows you to do really cool stuff out
there so what we build for graph girl
usually is a normalized cache and by
normalized I mean imagine if you stored
in your cache the same shape as you
received in your responses
imagine I query all products with their
price and I query one product ID one
with its price if I stored it in their
original shape the product with ID one
in the first query and this product
would ID one would be in separate places
right because one is nested under
products and the other one would be
nested into like a serialized like
product
one key maybe so if I fetch this first
and another of you fetches the product
with the second query we're gonna get
two results possibly one's gonna be
outdated and one's gonna be right so the
way client caches work is we normalize
that data all right so in products let's
say that's my first query instead of
having the the image inside we're
actually just going to give it an ID or
use his existing ID and place it in
another key so now both queries can
fetch that for that image so relay and
apollo' are both examples of client-side
caches and you're really great since we
ask all the data on the client we can
now do really cool stuff right
I have everything I have presented in my
cache and I'm sending a query I can do
clever stuff like seeing the query I'm
standing right now do I have some data
that I don't need in cache already and
we can actually diff the ast from the
graphical query and what do we have in
the cache and only send what we really
need right so it helps minimize queries
even more security so if you read about
graph drill on Hacker News or forums in
general there's always a question like
oh you're letting users like query your
database like it's the most awful thing
ever but by now you probably understand
that like I said earlier it's basically
just a layer right and we define our
schema ourselves we never expose
something we don't want to expose but
there's still stuff that evil people
could do right since it can be deeply
nested people can create like malicious
queries and have like I don't know like
a million level of death because it can
be circular right so there's a different
different techniques to defend that
right we can use simple timeouts after
one second if my query hasn't resolved
just at ROI and garbage we can limit
query death so I can say nothing in my
data
gonna be deeper than like ten levels so
if somebody tries to queries if I'm
executing a graphical Korean I'm like
level a hundred it doesn't make any
sense right so we said like a max query
death of like then we can also use query
complexity so in my since I'm defining a
schema I can define this field costs
twenty and this fields is more expensive
for me to fetch so it cost a hundred and
then we can define a max complexity that
somebody can query that's pretty cool
future so yeah all of what I've talked
about until now is in the spec and I'm
using it right now
but there's also some really cool stuff
coming up one example is subscriptions
subscriptions are pretty much like a
query a read except you're telling graph
QL I want that now but also as soon as
it changes and every time it changes I
want updates so you can imagine this
could be implemented with like
WebSockets or server side events but
graph QL doesn't force you to use any
technology so you could implement if you
implement a spec you can use whatever
you want different queries are something
that are really awesome to the principle
is basically when I'm rendering some UI
what I want is showing something to the
user as fast as possible right I want
them to like feel like it's it's really
it's really fast so what if when I query
I could ask the server send me name and
description as soon as you can if
loading the products takes more time
just defer it to later and we can
actually do that with that that's called
directive with the add sign here and
it's telling graph QL just split up the
query send me the first part that I
really need and send me the other part
later so yeah that's that was graph QL
so what I really like about graph 12
and obviously rest is still its
simplicity is just so awesome right so
graphical might not need meet the needs
of everyone if you have like a recent
really simple app if you have a lot of
caching and you don't want to use like a
complex client app rest might still be
the perfect choice right but if you have
like complex UI is like we usually have
these days it's much more complex than
before right like before it was a static
page and it's basically just what I have
in database I just show it right now we
have like much more complex and much
more nested objects graph grill is great
so graph coil exposes all the
possibilities and a server can do and in
clients just choose what they want right
it makes it really simple if you have an
Android app if you have a web app if you
have other servers they can all talk to
graph QL in the same way and you don't
need special endpoints thank you
[Applause]